see I am honestly trying to be on the
show and not do that I've had some
situations but as I knew it would come
with it I'm not trying to scare the
money off I'm really on there for a a
bigger purpose to use the show like to
be a billboard hey cardi B was on it
right for sure and she made it I think
it was supposed to kick the door down
for people to be like Ah that's a
reality show chick because yeah now
cardi B's yeah cardi B cardi B cardi B I
can't wait to get mine yeah she
definitely broke the mode I think a lot
of women get on the show and the money
is good and they become complacent
because it's like this is a job I get
paid for and there's no larger goal so
um the show has reached out to me three
times in the last five years so you had
said no prior two times yeah so that so
what made it right this time to
um they're gonna showcase my music and
focus more on I told them you got catty
[__] on the show that do their things
they're already getting paid more than
me let them stay in their position and
then you got the newcomers like me like
I'm focused on the music the show flew
out to Texas with me
um they come to my studio sessions they
come to my rehearsals like I wanted to
be about the music and you know in the
beginning it was like no this kind of
works what we're doing here so we want
you to do this and I just first two
times like no
um I'm making decent enough money
already without this so this go around
thankfully they are focusing more on
really who I am in the music and not
kind of making me try to date somebody
or hang out with the [__] I don't
know they're taking it back so I think
how it started and I'm glad that they're
doing that this year so that's why I'm
gonna come on I do feel like when I want
like would see shows like that I'd be
like it feels like so many of these
beefs and relationships and [__] are
just like four storylines
you know it's crazy I thought the same
thing until now that I'm in it it's real
it's really real but how it happens
which makes it kind of turn and look
like is this real
sometimes the beefs are so old and so if
this if I had this argument big fall out
with you three weeks ago we know this
happened the whole cast knows it and
then a month later when it comes out me
and you might have squashed it so I'm at
your listening party and it's like [__]
y'all were just on the show fighting on
Monday but but the episode is old it's
old people don't really know how it it
works as far as the process of rolling
out so you see us out with the person
it's like I knew that was fake it's no
way y'all was really arguing like that
but it was six weeks ago we filmed that
you didn't know that right so it's a lot
it's definitely real you know you have
some who exaggerated but it's definitely
real uh talk about the music what do you
got going on on the music side what's on
the way what's out yeah yeah that part
so I just dropped a um single car bag
ladies doing really good drop the video
behind it um shout out to bigger Rankin
he hosted this hey bigger ranking that's
a Florida Legend yes definitely did you
see the video yet I have not seen the
video you got to check it out let's
watch it together let's give you my
review hold on we got YouTube right here
right here let's watch it together let
me just ain't gonna look at me
all right here we go
God damn it why can't we have a keyboard
that connects to the [__] TV
because it's on Amazon here
it's right there
wait the video's on Amazon the keyboards
are like oh the wireless one
you just hook it up look I see you there
you go right there
bag lady
okay featuring bigger Ranka produced by
mob Glizzy shout out to mob Glizzy shout
out to bigger
[Music]
for real
all right
you're like hey you know what give me
that baby great for the video handed me
the baby I was like
uh
you have great abs
free I've been working for you those are
natural yes well you know I gotta ask
these days sometimes there's these girls
out here getting the
you can buy that yeah [__] I've been
thinking about it and you might end up
looking like a lobster tail I look like
that dude band man Kevo a lobster tail
look like a Ninja Turtle
I like this
um
look at that baby you don't want to be
there though
and that lady still hits me on Instagram
it's so funny she's like your nephew's
like five months now I'm like oh yeah I
love it
it was so cute though
fire you [__] with it I do and I and you
give honest so I would I would tell you
otherwise I like it
where'd you find the money room on peer
space so that is one of my mom's
businesses it's on peer space it's
called the pink and blue house so it's
um the first ever uh pink and blue
gender reveal house the entire home but
at the top is four different rooms sets
different sets yeah she's getting that
money getting that money shout out to
Mom yes yes shout out to Mom on the way
I don't have an album on away but I am
dropping a six song EP called Amy's
World
um we release bag ladies just to set the
tone for the bars and the sound and now
we're about to drop a EP is coming out
on June 13th which is actually the day
that the show premieres it makes sense
right perfect perfect time so people be
like who's this chick beating the [__]
out of Erica Maine on TV oh she got an
idiot out yeah that part so yeah June
13th I'm excited about that we actually
completed the EP maybe two weeks ago
we're doing the process of everything
getting mixed and mastered and getting
the visuals and stuff together I'm
excited to drop it I'm excited to be a
little more vocal about music I think
that personally
people have viewed me as like the social
media girl or like this popular YouTube
girl and this girl goes viral and it's
like yeah that's a part of me but this
is what I really do and I hadn't really
put real energy into it because life how
it lives so this EP is important to me